[Music]
English lessons today's mini English
lesson is about how to form questions in
English I'm going to give you a simple
formula that works for almost any
question with almost any verb there is
one main verb that doesn't work with
this formula I'll tell you what it is at
the end of the video but your challenge
is to try and think of it before we get
to it so the formula I have for you
today is an acronym called quaza that's
Q W a s it stands for questions word
auxilary subject main verb and it works
for almost any question if you want to
make a question in the present simple we
might want to ask where do you work
where is our question word do is the
auxiliary
U is the subject and work is the main
file remember for the present simple we
have to add the auxiliary do or does for
he she and it what does she think what
question word does auxilary she subject
and think main but if you want to make a
question in the present continuous you
already have the auxilary which is and
is or are what is he talking about what
question word is auxiliary he subjects
talking mentha then when we make
questions in the past simple we need to
add the auxiliary again and this time
it's did and it's the same for every
subject so what did I say what did you
want we can also make questions like
this in the past continuous like in the
present continuous we have the auxilary
it was or were what was I thinking
it works as well for questions in the
present perfect for example how much
money have you spent and it works in the
future
when will we meet again if you want to
make a question with a modal verb you
just have to replace the auxilary with a
motor so if your modal is good
your question might be how could we
improve our English there are some
exceptions to this rule firstly if you
want to ask a yes-or-no question then
you just need to remove the question
word but you can still keep the second
half of the acronym which is the ASM as
an auxilary subject may infer for
example the question could be do you
like chocolate there is one verb that
never uses this structure did you think
of it it's the verb to be when we make a
question with to be we simply invert the
subject and the verb so the statement I
am hungry becomes the question am i
hungry and the answer is always yes now
you have everything that you need to go
out there and make perfect questions in
English and all you have to do is get
out there and practice so I have a
question for you what are you waiting
for
[Music]